اهلا بكم في وصفات اكثر من 1000 مزرعه في
منطقه الحدود الشماليه السعوديه نجاح نواف
الزاهد في الزراعه العضويه بانواع متعدده
من المحاصيل الزراعيه في المشروع الذي
يهدف الى ان يكون مزار سياحيا لمحبي
الاماكن الريفيه تفاصيل مع جزاء عن مصر
[موسيقى]
في بيئه صحراويه ووسط اكثر من 1000 مزرعه
في منطقه الحدود الشماليه السعوديه نجحا
نواف الزاهد في الزراعه العضويه بانواع
متعدده من المحاصيل في بيوت محميه من
صندوق التنميه الزراعيه كاول مشروع من
نوعه في المنطقه مزارع زهدي مشروع زراعي
جديد عمره الان خمس سنوات حصل على شهاده
الانتاج العضوي كاول مزرعه في منطقه حدود
الشماليه فدانا في زراعه الخضار بانواعه
الورقيات في انواع الطماط الخيار الكوشه
الباذنجان همم والان نقوم بتوزيع الى
اسواق المنطقه
عرعر المحافظه قاعد يسوق الخضار يوميا
بسيارات مبرده همم بدانا بالنخيل من
البريحي نجح عندنا
نجاح طيب زيتون كذلك بدانا فيه من ما
يقارب الخمس سنوات والان انتاجوا طيب
مشروع الزاهديه الزراعي الذي تبلغ مساحته
اكثر من 300,000 متر مربع بات وجهه سياحيه
الريفيه في المنطقه يستقبل زواره ببيت من
الشعر وجلسات خاصه وسط الاشجار همم صلاه
المعتمده صلاه بالكربونات الزجاجيه همم
اربع صلاه الان بدا فيها زراعه الفراوله
وهمم واضافه الى البيوت السابقه العاديه
25 بيت المحل بعد ما حصلنا على الدعم من
صندوق التنميه الزراعي همم الانتاج وفير
ولله الحمد همم وكذلك عندنا خطوط مستقبليه
ان شاء الله ريفي وجلسات ريفيه لاستقطاب
بجوار المنطقه هذا المشروع الذي قضيه بدعم
صندوق التنميه الزراعيه في اكثر من 10
ملايين الريال يسال قائمون عليه لان يكون
احد المزارع السياحيه ذات للريفيه من
صحراء محافظه العويقيله
جزاعا ماصي العربيه